[Musique]
alors vous voyez cet écrit je m'appelle
philippe liotard et je suis là pour vous
parler du no future
alors c'est la première fois qu'on en
parle depuis ce matin effectivement de
suite sa premi 6 pourtant c'est là c'est
de là que vient finalement toute cette
idée du no future
alors pourquoi j'en parle j'en parle
parce que figurez-vous qu'en 1977
j'avais pas tout à fait 14 ans j'étais à
londres en angleterre et en 1977
peut-être que les plus anciens s'en
rappelle
c'était l'anniversaire des 25 ans du
règne de la reine elizabeth le queens
silver jubilé et donc c'était un
événement hallucinant pour les anglais
tout le monde de regarder ça à la
télévision
tout le monde ne parlait que de ça des
25 ans du règne et pour montrer ça à mes
parents j'ai rapporté un mug
ah oui c'est un mug originale des 25 ans
de la reine alors c'était vraiment super
g j'ai failli mais la reine à ce moment
là puisque tout le monde aimait en
angleterre je savais pas ce que c'était
qu'une reine puisque les nôtres est ce
que je savais pas c'est qu'à ce moment
là
au même moment un petit groupe de punk
rock encore inconnue qui s'appelait les
sex pistols avait construit un hommage à
la reine chanter une chanson en hommage
à la reine s'appelait god save the queen
mais vous voyez tout de suite que ce god
save the queen s'est légèrement
irrévérencieux pour ne pas dire un crime
de lèse majesté et on voit déjà une
façon de se moquer de la reine mais
c'est pourtant de là que vient cette
idée du no future
l'idée d'associer le pain que le
mouvement punk au no future pourquoi le
no future
vous voyez là derrière moi johnny rotten
le chanteur des sex pistols qui chante
dans ce god save the queen des ruines
ophiuchi nov
fioutch nos fioutch nord
fioutch foia avec les yeux complètement
halluciné cassé en deux sur son micro
très éloignés des beatles
il faut garder ses repères en tête
alors on a dit que le pain qui était le
mignot futur pourtant pourtant si on
écoute bien la chanson les paroles sont
pas très compliqué mais visiblement les
analyses de textes sont encore
nécessaires on s'aperçoit que dans cette
chanson
le no future c'est pas un rejet du futur
c'est un rejet des ruines nos futurs
england's dreaming dans les rêves dans
les fantasmes de cette angleterre là à
l'angleterre de la reine d'angleterre
l'angleterre des lords l'angleterre qui
est une société policée inégalitaire que
disent les sexpistols dans la chanson
aussi ils disent oui à de futures nous
sommes le futur nous sommes les fleurs
dans la poubelle distille et donc
renverse la poubelle c'est pas les pins
que c'est l'angleterre
nous sommes les fleurs mais des fleurs
qui font peur we are the future mais un
futur qui fait peur parce que la
jeunesse que l'on voit c'est une
jeunesse qui sent les 10 c'est une
jeunesse qui adoptent des comportements
des vêtements qui sont complètement
inadaptés à l'ordre corporelle
britannique et très vite à l'ordre
corporelle français européens etc etc
c'est une jeunesse qui va faire preuve
d'innovation d'innovation dans sa façon
de paraître c'est une façon de paraître
qui va multiplier
l'utilisation de bijoux ce qu'on va
appeler le piercing du tatouage sur les
mains sur le visage dans le coup sur le
crâne sur le coude également bien sûr
les vêtements les doc martins qui sont
des des chaussures de docker vont
devenir des sorties des chaussures de
sortie qu'on va mettre pour faire style
avec une mini jupe et des bas résilles
et si possible déchiré donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui va bousculer les
usages du bijou l'épinglé à nourrice
vous avez vu sur la fiche il ya une
épingle à nourrice c'est pas le hasard
c'est pas parce qu'on vous prend pour
des bébés c'est parce que il ya ce
rapport à l'épinglé à nourrice qui
devient un bijou tout comme le trombone
tout comme la lame de rasoir qu'on va
porter en sautoir tout comme le cadenas
tout comme les colliers de chien etc etc
finalement on ça
perçoit que les peintres ont le sens du
style le sens d'un style que j'appelle
le fuck your style c'est à dire c'est
une manière de paraître qui sans le dire
dis allez vous faire
il suffit de paraître il suffit de se
promener dans les rues de paris dans le
métro de de londres avec les crêtes les
blousons cloutés pour dire à tout le
monde on vous emmerde
cette apparence ce look cette
transgression finalement est quelque
chose qui alors largement bousculé et
qui a entretenu cet imaginaire pinc
pourtant les pins qu'on laissait des
icônes des icônes qu'on retrouve encore
aujourd'hui sur les murs de berlin sur
les murs de londres sur les murs de
paris peut-être même sur les murs de la
rochelle si on cherche bien j'en ai pas
trouvé assez pour ça que je me permets
et donc ses potes là vous en avez un
certain nombre site vicieuse johnny
rotten indie pop que vous avez sans
doute vu dans des publicités
joe strummer le chanteur du clash nina
hagen au dessus et puis patti smith
qu'on appelle la papesse la papesse du
pain que patti smith vous connaissez la
chanteuse figurez vous que c'est pas une
chanteuse s'est d'abord une poétesse
c'est quelqu'un qui s'est mis par hasard
à la chanson parce qu'un jour on la
demandait de décliner clamer ses poèmes
à new york et puis un quelqu'un qui a
pris sa guitare électrique qui
l'accompagné et ça a donné quelque chose
d'assez extraordinaire
elle a repris ses poèmes avec de la
musique et puis c'est devenu patti smith
la chanteuse alors que toute sa vie elle
a écrit elle a produit des choses qu'ils
avaient envie de produire peut-être
connaissez-vous également jean paul
gaultier le couturier est aussi peintre
gay et cumule may cumul et y cumule dans
le fait de casser les codes en 1994 vous
donne les dates 1994 je sais qu'avec
était peut-être pas né mais si tout le
monde
1994 en jean paul gaultier fait défiler
des mannequins avec des piercings vous
reconnaissez ses piercings avec la
chaînette qui passe de l'oreille à la
lèvre ou au nez et puis des piercings
qu'on appelle le symptôme la justice''
sur le sous le nez qui sont aujourd'hui
les persie parmi les plus pratiquées
dans les boutiques de piercings qui
n'existaient pas d'ailleurs en 1994
donc là on a pâti smith jean paul
gaultier des gens très différents qui
font pas de musique ou pas seulement et
qui sont dans ce quelque chose qui est
en train de générer une nouveauté vous
connaissez rachid taha peut-être moins
rachita qui a chanté en arabe
rock the casbah un titre phare du clash
mais qui sont tout connu en france pour
avoir chanté alors qu'il taille j'ai
rien quand même
d'où ce france en reprenant charles
trenet avec un groupe qui s'appelait
carte de séjour vous voyez tout de suite
c'est l'irrespect de ces algériens qui
sont chez nous et qui font des chansons
avec notre patrimoine
pourquoi je parle de rachid taha d'abord
parce qu'il est mort il ya quelques
semaines et c'est une façon de lui
rendre hommage
par ailleurs rachita est considéré à
lyon d'où je viens sur les pentes de la
croix rousse dont je vais parler
maintenant comme le grand frère des pins
qu il chante en français en algérien il
joue du rail et c'est le frère dépeinte
pourquoi parce que rachida fait partie
de ces gens qui ont créé des lieux qui
ont innové qui ont proposé à des jeunes
qui savaient pas où jouent et qui savait
pas où répéter qu'il savait pas comment
faire une tournée
il leur a appris sur le tas à faire des
choses parce qu'ils avaient envie de les
faire et c'est là sur la croix rousse
sur ces pentes de la croix-rousse qu'on
a eu à un moment dans les années 80-90
un grand foisonnement d'artistes
plasticiens peintres photographes
graphistes qui ont créé plein de choses
musiciens bien sûr musiciens et qu'elle
est ou bien au taux de rage ita ou bien
qu'ils allaient investir avec
marie-claire corde à une artiste
plasticienne et performeuse des squats
pour permettre aux jeunes qui n'avaient
pas d'argent et qu'ils voulaient créer
d'avoir des ateliers immense pour
pouvoir faire ce qu'ils avaient envie de
faire
vous connaissez virginie despentes les
chiennes savantes ça se passe à lyon sur
les pentes de la croix rousse
j'ai des pentes son pseudo vient des
pentes de la croix rousse où elle était
elle-même par
dans les années 80 et c'est pas hasard
qu aujourd'hui virginie despentes soit
une romancière qui a été comment connu
d'abord parbayse mois et qui fait avec
vernon subutex une sorte de panorama de
la société contemporaine extrêmement
percutant aujourd'hui virginie despentes
continue non pas écrire bien sûr qu'elle
écrit mais elle est en train de tourner
en ce moment avec une autre banque
béatrice dalle est un groupe de musique
pop de rock le groupe 0 sur des textes
de pier paolo pasolini finalement que
fait-elle avec béatrice dalle
elles se font plaisir elles font ce
qu'elles ont envie de faire et c'est ça
qui va rester dans la volonté de créer
quelque chose qu'on a envie de créer
parce que ça a du sens alors on va
arrêter de parler des artistes parce que
ce no future il se traduit au quotidien
par exemple on va pouvoir construire son
apparence comme on le souhaite pour ce
faire une crête
pas besoin d'aller chez le coiffeur il
suffit d'avoir une tondeuse pas encore
besoin d'aller chez le coiffeur
aujourd'hui les footballeur du psg vont
chez le coiffeur pour avoir leur crête
il la paye très cher auprès de coiffeur
de brancher des champs elysées et ça n'a
rien de pâques c'est quand même très
intéressant parce que ce passage va nous
permettre de voir que il y à une
diffusion dans la société de choses qui
paraissaient très transgressif et qui
sont aujourd'hui complètement normalisée
au dessus de moi vous avez marre qui
marque y connaissez connaissez pas
marqué alors bon on est à la rochelle
a lyon tout le monde le connaît c'est le
premier perceur de lyon il a commencé à
percer en 94 dans l'arrière salle d'une
boutique de disques d'un disquaire tout
comme luc aspire à avignon au moment du
festival d'avignon en 93-94 il ouvre une
petite échoppe et pendant dix ans il n'a
pas arrêté de faire des trous ou alors
crasse en alsace eh bien on a des
personnes comme marquis lucas spira
crasse qui sont 3 pac-3 vrai punk qui
commença à faire quoi à percer leurs
camarades pour pouvoir porter les bijoux
que personne ne veut leur place et
et puis vont créer ce que aujourd'hui on
trouve partout les boutiques de
piercings même à la rochelle j'en ai vu
persie est à toi jouer à tout est
possible et donc on a la possibilité à
partir de ces années-là de travailler
son corps comme on le souhaite et au
même moment au même moment les
techniques vont se diversifier
on va inventer aux etats unis les
implants notamment les implants trans
thermique dont ça fait pas mal hein même
si on met la main n'ayez pas peur
vous avez le crâne le crâne de samba
fall série bones qui est un artisan de
la chaire mondialement connue
aujourd'hui et qui finalement a
simplement placer des bijoux comme ça
qui sont placés à travers la pause sur
un petit pas de vis qui permet de
choisir le type de coiffure que l'on
veut porter je vous donnerai les
coordonnées si vous le souhaitez j'avais
pas pensé mais sinon j'aurais pu mettre
les adresses en tout cas les adresses
mail
et puis c'est un plan comme on va le
voir sur elza juste après ces implants
peuvent aussi être des implants subir
milk vous voyez là trois petites étoiles
sous la peau placé sur l'avant bras ce
qui permet de produire une sculpture de
soi une culture une sculpture son propre
corps alors je vais me permettre de
faire quelque chose que je n'avais pas
prévu du tout mais c'est aujourd'hui
l'anniversaire d'elsa donc je lui
souhaite un bon anniversaire s'il est en
direct elle nous verra et puis sinon on
les enverra le lien vers l'est vers la
vidéo donc bonne anniversaire elsa grâce
à toi j'ai pu parler des implants sub
dermique alors tout ça
ce désir de devenir soi ce désir de
devenir la personne que l'on cherche de
devenir celui ou celle que l'on ait ce
do it yourself
on va le trouver y compris dans des
logiques qui sont des logiques qui
peuvent nous paraître extrême
extrêmement transgressive
vous avez la chjama ta femme dragons qui
étaient les hôtes à tous et à tous et
sur le visage un plan bien sûr qui est
même allé jusqu'à se faire retirer les
oreilles pour mettre en cohérence son
apparence donc on peut se dire
effectivement ça va très loin
ça va très loin oui mais ce qui va très
loin c'est la possibilité pour chacune
et pour chacun d'aller là où il ou elle
souhaite vous allez me dire pourquoi il
nous parle de tout ça pourquoi il nous
parle de ses malades
si vous riez c'est que vous pensez
vraiment que ce sont des malades en
général eh bien figurez vous qu'il ya
quelques semaines sur son compte
instagram patti smith a présenté cette
image dans laquelle elle dit le punk
rock c'est la liberté de créer c'est la
liberté d'avoir du succès c'est la
liberté de ne pas avoir de succès la
liberté d'être soi c'est la liberté
et c'est cette liberté est le résultat
du no future dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure c'est cette liberté qui
aujourd'hui possiblement accessible à
toutes les personnes qui le souhaitent
alors bien sûr vous allez voir vous
allez peut-être être impressionné par
des personnes telles que j'ai été
présenté que vous pourriez croiser dans
la rue qui sont pour la plupart d'entre
elles des personnes charmante mais qui
par leur apparence produisent du rejet
sauf qu'en produisant du rejet elle
produit aussi du désir pas chez les
mêmes personnes le désir de devenir soi
le désir de se construire par rapport à
un imaginaire par rapport à un désir que
l'on a soi-même de se transformer pour
devenir la personne que l'on imagine
c'est la possibilité qui donnait à
chacune et à chacun d'expérimenter ce
désir qui coule comme le dirait le
philosophe gilles deleuze ce désir qui
coule et qu'on peut expérimenter qu'on
peut aller chercher à tout moment de la
vie à tout moment où tout d'un coup on
se dit j'ai envie d'y aller j'y vais
deux hits do it yourself do your body
yourself fais ton corps toi-même fais ce
que tu veux créer et tout le monde peut
le faire à son niveau pour soi y compris
dans sa chair pas pour se
détruire et pour se construire les sales
gosses rebelles convoyé au début les
pimbêche revêche n'imaginais pas à leurs
futurs et ne se projetait pas dans le
futur mais en faisant ça ils ont produit
des possibilités de devenir
on n'est pas ce que l'on est
on n'est pas seulement seul que l'on est
on est ce que l'on devient être punk
c'est être libre être poc c'est être
libre
est ce que nous laisse le no future le
no 'future' c'est le fait que nous
sommes notre futur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]